this is apple's brand new 2020 10.2 inch
ipad
which retails for 329
and this is apple's 2020 11 inch ipad
pro
which retails for 800. so let's compare
them
to see if it's actually worth spending
the extra cash for the pro
now i know what you're thinking the ipad
pro should not be compared
to the budget ipad because it's in a
whole different league
but it's definitely worth seeing just
how much more features
and value you get by spending over twice
the cash
especially now that the budget ipad
finally gets
a really fast processor as you'll see
later on
in this video so let's jump right into
this detailed comparison there are six
major differences between these two
ipads
design cameras displays
the usability of the apple pencil the
ports
and performance so let's start with the
design
the budget ipad feels a bit old with
large white bezels all around
a touch id sensor and classic chamfered
edges
the pro really stands out thanks to its
modern design
with squared off edges a flat back and
black bezels on the front
that hide the face id system which by
the way
works much better than you'd think
compared to touch id
the pro is also much thinner than the
regular ipad
which is actually really impressive one
of the biggest design differences
is that the ipad pro gets two additional
speakers on the top
so you get true stereo sound in
landscape mode
for a more immersive experience just
listen for yourself to hear the volume
[Music]
[Music]
difference
[Music]
[Music]
now the cameras aren't as important but
the pro comes with a 7 megapixel camera
on the front
instead of 1.2 megapixels on the basic
ipad
as well as a 12 megapixel camera on the
back instead of 8 megapixels
allowing for really sharp photos the
ipad pro
also now gets an ultra wide lens which
is a nice little bonus
and of course you get the new lidar
scanner which is useful for augmented
reality apps and other things like that
the pro also gets better microphones so
here's a quick comparison so you can
hear the difference
this is a video and microphone quality
test with the 2020
10.2 inch ipad this is a selfie video
and audio quality test with the
2020 ipad pro moving on to display
differences
the ipad pro has a much more modern
rounded corner display
which is much more immersive you can
also tell that the regular ipad has less
contrast
even with the display off and it's
definitely much more reflective as well
the ipad pro has a laminated display
which basically means that the screen is
literally glued to the glass
the basic ipad does not have that so you
can notice a gap of
air under the glass and above the
display this also makes it feel and
sound
a little bit hollow compared to the very
solid feeling ipad pro
the pros display is quite a bit brighter
than the regular ipad's display
and it also supports p3 wide color gamut
so it can display a wider range of
colors like this specific shade of red
that you can't see on the regular ipad
the ipad pro also gets true tone
technology
so the white balance of the display
adjusts to match your surroundings
so it's easier on the eyes one of the
biggest display features that the ipad
pro gets is
pro motion technology which basically
allows it to refresh at up to 120 hertz
so it feels incredibly smooth while
swiping through the ui
and you can enjoy high refresh rate
games the cherry on top is that it
automatically adjusts down to as low as
24 hertz
to match the content you're viewing to
help save battery life while the regular
ipad is always stuck
at 60hz pro motion also helps the ipad
pro
achieve a very low 9 milliseconds of
latency
compared to the budget ipad which you
can tell has a lot more lag
in this slow motion clip the pro also
gets the second generation apple pencil
which comes with a new design that
supports wireless charging
right on the side of the ipad pro it's a
bit more expensive
at a hundred and thirty dollars instead
of a hundred dollars for the original
pencil
but it's great that you don't have to
deal with the old way of charging it
on top of that the 2nd gen pencil gets a
new double tap
gesture that allows you to quickly
switch between tools
and yes there are many third-party apps
that support it as well
and because the budget ipad's display is
not laminated
there's a noticeable gap between the
pencil's tip
and the drawing especially when looking
at it from an angle
now moving on to the ports the basic
ipad gets a headphone jack
which the pro doesn't get instead the
pro gets a usbc
port which is really nice because you
get more power for connecting
accessories and storage drives compared
to the very limited lightning port
on the budget ipad now before we move on
to comparing the performance
there are a couple of spec differences
that you need to know but first be sure
to check out our apple product merch
like our apple product t-shirt and our
mask
down in the merch shelf below
surprisingly the budget ipad now comes
with the brand new
20 watt usbc power adapter while the
2020 ipad pro gets the older
18 watt usbc charger so that was
definitely unexpected
the pro gets bluetooth 5 instead of 4.2
and it also gets wi-fi 6 with
simultaneous dual band
for a more reliable connection now
finally getting into performance
the 2020 ipad pro's a12z bionic chip
is still the best mobile chip ever made
even better than the new a14 chip and
the new ipad air
which we are going to be getting so
subscribe right now if you want to see
those comparison videos
the 2020 ipad on the other hand has now
finally been updated with the a12 chip
which is much more powerful than the
previous a10 fusion chip
but the ipad pro is still around 80
faster
in terms of the processor now i also
tested the graphics performance
and this is by far the biggest
difference
the ipad pro's a12 z chip is around 2.3
times more powerful
in the metal test which is a massive
difference
even though the ipad is still much
faster than it was before
now i know you're gonna say it's
obviously much faster because
it's much more expensive but that
graphic score on the ipad pro
is better than intel's brand new 10th
gen chip
in the top end 2020 13 inch macbook pro
on top of that the ipad pro gets double
the ram
6 gigabytes compared to 3 gigabytes on
the basic ipad
so it's going to be better for heavy
multitasking and things like photo and
video editing
playing call of duty mobile the basic
ipad now runs it very well
thanks to that new chip so it's a great
gaming experience
and the graphics still look really nice
on the ipad pro
you can basically max out all of the
settings and never have to worry about
any dropped frames the main benefit of
the ipad pro is for playing games that
support 120 frames per second
making it just about the best gaming
experience
you can get on any apple device or any
tablet and you also get stereo speakers
which allow you to hear enemies
footsteps around you
in first person shooter games and of
course this performance will also
translate over into the overall feel of
using the ipad itself
and other professional workflow apps now
the final thing i want to compare before
we answer the original question
is keyboard case support the absolute
best option for the budget ipad is the
logitech
combo touch which comes with a very
solid and protective case
a pretty nice keyboard with a row of
function keys at the top
and a built-in trackpad which supports
three finger gestures
just like you get on a macbook the best
part is that it connects using the smart
connector
which means no lag no batteries and no
having to connect
using bluetooth so for a hundred and
fifty dollars that case is a great value
since it basically turns this
ipad into a laptop replacement that
beats out a lot of chromebooks
now for the ipad pro you have two great
options
the first is the new magic keyboard
which is basically
the best keyboard case ever made coming
with a super nice
modern design which attaches using
nothing but magnets
and the hinge design allows the ipad pro
to float in the air
closer to you for a more convenient
experience
it also comes with a usb-c charging port
built into the hinge
which allows you to use the main port
for connecting accessories and storage
drives
so it's perfect for power users the only
downside is that it costs a hefty
300 but luckily logitech also created
the folio touch keyboard case
for only 160 bucks which is almost
identical to the combo touch
for the budget ipad so that's a great
choice if you want to save some cash
so with all of that said let's finally
answer the
original question should you spend the
extra cash on the ipad pro
well first off it comes with 128 gigs of
storage at the base price
compared to only 32 gigs with the budget
ipad
so if you match both of them up with 128
gigs
there's now only a 370 difference
which obviously is still a lot more to
spend but
based on all the advantages it's
definitely worth it
for some people like for example if you
take drawing
very seriously buy the ipad pro because
it works just so much better
and if you want very high end
performance the ipad pro
is the fastest tablet ever made and if
you care a lot about display quality
the cameras the microphones or speaker
quality
the ipad pro is definitely the better
choice and since it's packing the new
modern design with the square edges and
the usb-c port
it'll still feel fresh and modern years
down the road
while the design of the basic ipad is
starting to look
outdated and it'll most likely be
redesigned next year
so basically if you're a power user or
you care about having the best display
the best performance or you really care
about the new modern design
then spending the extra cash on the ipad
pro is definitely worth it for you
however there are also some really great
reasons to buy
the basic 10.2 inch ipad like if you're
on a budget
the a12 chip now makes it feel much more
snappy for day-to-day use
and it's also more than fast enough for
even the newest games on the app store
like call of duty mobile and if you
mainly want to consume media like
youtube or netflix
the ipad is gonna have no issues at all
for that
apart from the speakers which aren't as
good but you can always connect
headphones or your airpods
that new a12 chip is gonna allow it to
run very fast and
reliably for years and it's also a much
better choice
compared to a chromebook thanks to the
excellent new logitech combo touch
keyboard case
which makes it the perfect budget laptop
replacement
but to answer the original question
because of that a12
chip i honestly have to say that the
budget 10.2 inch ipad for 329
is now a better choice this year for
almost
everyone being the best bang for the
buck ipad we've
ever seen but all of that might change
when the ipad pro finally gets updated
again
which might actually happen later this
year according to minkshakuo
so if you're excited for that go ahead
and tap the like button below
and click the circle above to subscribe
and if this video helped to make a
decision
on which ipad to buy please use our
amazon links down below to help support
this channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you